[Musik]
hey meine süßen heute gibt einen
zitronen cheesecake mit zitronen soße
total lecker und frisch passend zum
wetter und ihr habt mir dabei geholfen
ich hab nämlich gerade auf instagram
abgestimmt ob ich jetzt was mit zitrone
oder was mit kirschen machen soll
und das rezept es kommt dann irgendwann
so und ich fange jetzt ja auch direkt an
dich schnecke gar nicht großartig
drumherum wir brauchen für den boden
butterkekse und boccia und ich habe sie
die butterkekse schon mal fein gemahlen
könnte auch einfach nudelholz nehmen und
draufhauen
hauptsache sie sind fein dann geben die
geschmolzene butter dazu und verrühren
das und falls ihr euch wundert wo stehen
in die mengenangaben die findet ihr alle
unten in der video beschreibung so
einmal verrühren und dann nehme ich mir
gleich auch schon meine 24er springform
den bodensee mit backpapier auskleiden
und dann den keks boden schön android
[Musik]
der keks boden ist jetzt einfach im
kühlschrank lagert in einfach dort bis
es weitergeht und ich habe jetzt hier
meine zutaten bereit stehen benutzt die
küchenmaschine ihr könnt den alternativ
auch mit ganz viel kraft einfach mit den
händen und mit einem schneebesen rühren
und ich habe sie zuallererst magerquark
ich fange jetzt auch schon direkt an ich
gebe einmal magerquark rein in die
schüssel dann nehme ich gerne etwas
doppel ram frischkäse ich finde dass in
verbindung mit magerquark schmeckt total
cremig ich bin nicht so trocken sodass
ist auch drin
frischkäse wie gesagt nimmt hier keine
light-variante tun mir gefallen das ist
ganz wichtig dass ihr einfach nur doppel
ram frischkäse verwendet und sahne dient
nochmal der tätigkeit damit einfach nach
dem backen auch richtig schön für mich
ist und dann süßes ich das natürlich mit
zucker und bei meinen zitronen gebäcken
kommt immer vanille reimer ich finde
dass das super harmoniert so zucker und
vanille extrakt und dann kommt schon
unsere zitrone zum einsatz
[Musik]
jetzt ist es ganz wichtig wie ihr eure
zitronenschale reibt erstens muss es
eine bio zitrone sein ich möchte dir
nicht die schadstoffe aus der schale
haben sondern es soll komplett
unbehandelt sein und dann ist es wichtig
was für ein bier verwendet ich nehme
jetzt hier meine feinen reibe dampf
macht überhaupt nichts falsch damals ich
musste auch erst die erfahrung machen
damals habe ich einfach die vier kann
treiber genommen die ich auch für salat
et cetera benutze und dann hatte ich
nach dem backen richtig dicke
zitronenschalen stücke im gaumen und
dann war der ganze kuchen versorgt daher
spart da bitte nicht und investiert in
so was und dann noch ganz ganz wichtig
es gibt bio zitrone die sind einmal so
hoch habe ich sogar die endstücke
abgeschnitten und diesen so klein also
ihr habt solche und solche die sind
total individuell und deswegen mache ich
euch am besten esslöffel angaben damit
falls jemand der so eine zitrone packt
mich sagt er hat mir gar nichts zitronig
genug geschmeckt und jemand der so einer
hat sagte aber viel zu sauer der kuchen
deshalb genau esslöffel angaben damit
mache ich glaube ich heute nichts falsch
und dann presse ich jetzt einfach noch
den saft rein informativ ja ja
[Musik]
so anschließend noch die eier dazugeben
und dann alles langsam verrühren bis es
sich verbindet das dauert ungefähr
eineinhalb bis zwei minuten
und ganz zum schluss rühren wir dann
noch speisestärke ein die ich zuvor
sieben damit wir keine klümpchen haben
und ist der teig fertig und wir für ihn
einmal in die springform ich kann aus
dem kühlschrank geholt habe zweimal
schön einfüllen und dann kann es auch
schon in den backofen ich verrate ich
auch schon mal die backzeit dass die
hitze 180 grad ober und unterhitze ganz
wichtig bitte vorheizen immer vorgeheizt
backen und zwar für 50 minuten es kann
auch zwei länger oder kürzer dauern
wichtig ist dass es dann anschließend
richtig schön abkühlen lässt und dann
zeige ich euch jetzt wie ihr die
zitronen soße macht also wieso sollte
ich doch jetzt hier aus schlecken da ja
jetzt schon flüssig ist auch heute sind
wir einfach mal spontan so zufrieden
sollte daraus schlüpfen hier aus aus
lecken super-job es gleich so für unsere
zitronen soße habe ich jetzt vorab
erstmal zitronen sagt ausgepresst und
weil er sehr sehr sauer ist nehme ich
natürlich auch zucker zum ausgleich ich
gebe direkt zitronensaft und so kann
hier einmal in den topf der herpes noch
aus so und da kommt noch speisestärke
dazu das soll jährlich sehr flüssig sein
sondern er hat saucen mäßig so ein
bisschen seliger auch mit dazu und dann
einmal unter rühren aufkochen lassen und
dann liegt es auch schon ein und ganz
zum schluss geben wir eben auch für die
konsistente ein bisschen butter mit dazu
[Musik]
kleiner trick vorweg ich gebe jetzt ein
bisschen lebensmittelfarbe rein damit
auch ansehnliche aussieht alternativ
könnt ihr natürlich auch orangensaft zum
beispiel
[Musik]
so die zitronen so sieht einfach
auskühlen lassen und wir müssen ja
sowieso noch auf den kuchen warten bis
er auskühlt
am besten schmeckt er wenn er richtig
schön im kühlschrank war dann aber eine
halbe stunde vom verzehr aus dem
kühlschrank nehmen dass es mein top tipp
für euch und dann gebe ich euch hiermit
die kicker garantie dass euch dieses
rezept schmecken wird wenn ihr zitronen
fans seid und oder andere chance und
sind mit so stempel kiki garantie
ja das war toll wenn das machen würdest
so ansonsten wünsche ich euch jetzt ganz
viel freude beim nachmachen
wir müssen uns ja jetzt auch noch ein
bisschen gedulden damit dass abkühlt und
ich denke mal auf instagram seht ihr
dann den test test von haben hier
er folgt uns gerne auf instagram damit
ihr dort auch nichts verpasst und auch
wie hier mit bestimmen könnt was du
alles schönes online kommt und dann
würde ich mal sagen
sehen wir uns aber im nächsten rezept
hier auf fitness kitchen teams
[Musik]
wo das möglich zitronig zu zitronig also
frisch dieses misstrauen ist ja wir
haben eine zitrone so sehr darüber
gemacht wo es ist von sommerlich das
passt jetzt perfekt ist
und ist er mächtig oder aber es ist
haben sie was ein richtiger fan slacker
perfekt was passt zum wetter
[Musik]